humph going bros my name is pierre ah
welcome to goat MMO simulator we are
logging in right now don't need a
password to log in in this game because
I don't know MMO which of course stands
for more manly ovaries yes of course
what do you really think what was all
about last episode we played as to what
the deadly explosive microwave but today
I want to try out the hunter I like my
basses that I have there I like my boots
but most of all I like how that fishing
rod is hovering above my ass
Disco's oh god ah M G says this fishing
rod hahaha look at it it's all dangly
hey I can smack his booty with it
I may be a hunter but I am a gentleman
goat a gentle goat gentleman goat let's
try out our new abilities on this dummy
goats one
I spawn a bass great what's the point of
me being a hunter if all I have to do is
hips yeah come on all right all right
all right all right shut up shut up shut
up what about our I picked them up
that's it
Jesus what is it what is that that's
damn oh damn I can use the fish it's out
of my weapons that's genius
oh my god let's try it on dude bro hey I
wanted to talk to you about that one
time you [ __ ] took my lunchbox damn
it
there we go nailed it all right good
enough for me let's go adventure all
right let's find a nuke whisperers Oh
what am i doing what a help of course
the hunter has great skills in walking
on top of on on defying gravity all
right here's the question goddamnit when
I met him at the market the other day he
called me a nerd oh no I gotta get
revenge could you break his beehives
well I don't oh here we go all right I
can do that buddy
don't you worry hey Caitlin how you
doing not so good I see oh you're fine
okay sorry this is nothing personal but
I have to wreck your beehives you know
what let's bring him as a hostage
all right I'd Lynn Olson I did your
quest that'll teach him to call me a
nerd I bet he's really sorry about that
now I'm not sure if the he's capable of
human emotion but what do I know I'm
just a goat have some fish you smell
like a fish at least oh whoa level 75
chip ganking starting area damn it I
hate when they do that oh you look like
a man who can appreciate a fish hey I
really feel like having a snack right
now well good thing I can spawn fishes
so I need to go to the Knights and the
elves to get the butter what's wrong
with my fishes you haven't even tried
them don't ride me you dirty [ __ ] this
game is so immersive I really feel I
really truly feel like I am a hunter
goat oh god oh god what I do why did I
do this Yale yeah good thing I wore my
boots what
what no no no no no no how do I get off
how do i oh my god holy what are you
doing up here what's up nerd I bet
you're not good enough to dad from here
from there all right you're free fishes
you're free yay all right you want to
dive you want to die [ __ ]
yay Quist done general sergeant latent
all right make it the battle plan is a
failure we need to infiltrate the even
sheep village twist friend we invented a
high-tech self device use the stealth
device to my right to infiltrate the
sheep village this is a stealth device
it doesn't look like one it looks more
like a Kadim oh god yeah go vicious warn
the king warn the king my fish damn it
hi guys oh god what oh my god oh my god
this is amazing fight me fight me fight
me with this stick it's not it really is
whatever damn it I can fly with it what
am i doing someone make it sound damn it
I don't know it's I don't know if this
is a good thing or a bad thing
Oh No Gandalf what'd I do - Gandalf I've
been trying to open a portal budget I
like a demonic horn sorry Gandalf
alright kind of you coming with me
Gandalf as cookie candles what the [ __ ]
that is so [ __ ] up haha alright we
have a we have a god damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it god damn it
I like how I swim in my little boots Oh
again what the [ __ ] are you kidding me
have a fish have a fish I have a fish
really though if well a walk I will
create a game like this everyone would
play it I would play it at least alright
we finished a quest over here
I don't [ __ ] know I didn't know I
took the quiz here there you are Kirkman
I find your judge cook now if only you
would let me go to you thank you let me
go to you get it
ha sorry see what's going on with my
goat I have two fishing rods - what the
they duplicate Siamese fishing rods or
some [ __ ] this game truly works in
mysterious ways
alright we shall go to the Knights and
those Polish people really know how to
grind alright we're going to deny to get
butter Oh No Satan what the [ __ ] Satan
what are you doing Satan Satan no dammit
Satan has the worst internet connection
Oh God
no God no damn it I was supposed to get
this stuff to the city and this damn
stick got stuck in the wheel troublesome
stick I don't have the arm strength can
you help me please
you stupid stick hey you go and with the
pants did I fix your problem it was this
stick you're very welcome
why why do you have to do that that's
really mean what what are you talking
about here have a fish and shut up
alright fine you can have two fishes I'm
such a good person
ooh that's the portal Isengard what to
take in two hobbits
can I go to Isengard no [ __ ] way can
I go to Isengard
would you like to travel stay oh my god
you're so awesome
this game is hot because of security you
can't I have to hold on to your things
get some a lot of barrels what are you
doing here better iPhone gotcha yes I
mean BAFF I'm better
I found better get it hi alright you
seriously need to get grab the damn
butter grab the damn butter
thank you thank you my good man here's
your butter
you're very welcome great now I have
some butter I need some sugar as well ah
come on what the [ __ ] is everyone on
meth on this in this game Kristen Wayne
hello Kristen Wayne
I lost my bail my parents I gotta go
crazy please can you help me find enough
damn it where is it then ah adventurer
you might have hunted animals for sports
before I don't know where you would get
that idea
but you are not to 200 until you've
killed something rare something so
unique that it okay in fact they live on
the Western field you must hunt down
every single one all right I can do that
if you don't you're not going to be cool
like me well that settles it
let's kill them are those two Dodos
alright Dodos we could settle this like
real men come on have it have it have it
have a fish I'm not right fine fine you
know what fine that's to chew dododododo
dead dota did say I kill all the Dodos
except one now this dodo is were super
much I'm so smart my mom would be so
proud of me being a dodo killer in a
video game I don't know anyway
dammit dammit dodo don't make this
harder don't know there you go dodo oh
shut up dodo you look go too [ __ ] well
done you might not you might not have
been the first so 200 but now you are
definitely the last tips hunting hat
oh I think he liked it a little too much
I caught you now huh how about dad how
does that make you feel your little
Pokemon bit what is it leo Ludacris
doing you want you bros want to go
through the portal let's go through the
port what is this okay yeah I needed the
crate what there's a whole new area Oh
May dad oh my god what is that kid doing
up there
oh my god it's ice raid she's totally
famous on the server man he gets all the
[ __ ] with those shoes - I only have
this rubber shitty shoes but but ice
rage he's the cool one ah too much to
explore I don't know where to begin
oh oh Jesus ah ah [ __ ] Oh God why why me
ah what's the hot gotta thank God huh I
didn't go anywhere
oh oh god dammit every time I miss it
there we go
what come on there we go take Y Matt
what's it I just want to fly dammit
there we go final dammit fine [ __ ] you
in your stupid catapult I don't need you
anyway ow my hand
ah yeah you kick I'm just not destined
to be a catapult I'm a nice hat buddy
where did you get it out oh oh oh oh
what is this ha ha
who's gonna be gay why what the [ __ ] ha
ha come on come on come on
one of those cow those cows is multiply
well now I've seen it all ha ha all
right first if you enjoy this video
leave a like and hit hit to watch the
next one be you do a live long and
prosper sales rose thank you watching
love you Baja